African leaders gathered at the African
Union in Ethiopia's capital Addis Ababa
for its annual Summit
the suspensions of Mali Guinea and
Burkina Faso following military coups
were upheld so the commit the commission
is ready
to support these member states
to return to constitutional order
Israel's delegation was escorted from
the meeting room by security Israel has
been seeking Observer status at the Au
for 20 years member states are still
divided on whether or not it should be
granted South Africa is against it
president Paul kagame of Rwanda met
president Felix Jessica of Democratic
Republic of Congo to talk about the
escalating conflict in Congo's East
Congo says it's fighting rwanda's Army
under the guise of the M23 armed group
Rwanda denies that M23 as its proxy
East African leaders issued yet another
statement calling for peace previous
statements in recent months haven't
stopped m23's Advance or the increasing
reports of rapes and massacres of
civilians
two weeks ago protesters in Congo
brought the eastern city of Goma to a
standstill they demanded that Kenyan and
other East African Regional forces
deployed in Congo either fight M23 or
leave is Kenya ready to to fight M23 or
even Rwanda in Congo Kenya is ready to
do what we agree as the East African
heads of state Kenya is the only country
that has deployed in in DRC we have
agreed that this military intervention
is going to be in parallel with a
political engagement of the combatants
on the ground M23 and all the other
fighting forces so that we can give
ourselves the best opportunity to
succeed a Free Trade Agreement that's
meant to remove tariffs and boost trade
between African countries was discussed
the African Free Trade Agreement has
been talked about here for years but
what's written on paper is far from the
reality
intra-african trade is less than it is
in most other continents economists say
it's been in Decline since 2012 and that
it's impaired not only by tariffs but
also by a lack of infrastructure and a
lack of freedom of movement of people
between the member states
the new chair for the year ahead is the
president of comoros azali asumani who's
jailed his political opponents and
changed the country's Constitution to
extend his rule
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera at the African
Union in Addis Ababa